[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you if you board
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guests this week is the
deputy editor of Spike magazine Tom
Slater
welcome to trigonometry it's great to
have you here and the first question we
always always ask is tell us a little
bit about how you got to be where you
are today yeah sure so and I found out
about spiked where I currently work
quite young actually so when I was about
17 I was involved in a program that
spike set up to give state school kids
in London I kind of leg up into
journalism so I met a lot of them free
doing that and basically just kind of
kept in contact originally always got
into kind of cultural journalism things
like that but slowly over the years got
more and more interested in politics got
more and more kind of radicalized and I
think especially my kind of experience
at university as far as looking around
for what sort of politics would like to
sign up for not really finding much of
interest on either left or right
despite increasingly seem to make a lot
of sense to me and seem to be something
I wanted to be and for those people who
don't know spikes who haven't
encountered in what is spiked and what
how could you sum up them politically so
I think our political benders really we
come out of the left and yet
increasingly find ourself raging against
to the left only which I think actually
a lot of people increasingly finding
themselves in so far as some of our kind
of foundational principles are things
like freedom of speech which I know
we'll be talking about democracy the
idea that society societies that are
constantly striving to produce more and
to produce a kind of higher standard of
living for everyone is something that's
it's something that should be the main
goal when you're increasing it feels
like the left are incredibly censorious
incredibly anti-democratic incredibly
environmentalist in the worst kind of
way which seems to be mainly about kind
of dampening down production saying that
people's lifestyles have gone too far
etcetera and I think really what that
whole kind of process tells us that
feels like the left-right divide doesn't
give you very much it doesn't explain
very much about where you come from
because these terms would be become so
distorted but the way I was described it
is that effectively we're kind of full
freedom democracy and plenty and I think
that's really what our guiding
principles are whether you want to label
that however you choose basically and
why do you think it is not because I say
to people oh you know we're doing a
YouTube channel we've got so and so on
from spite and it tends to be a sort of
distrust of the magazine occasionally
even mumblings or rumors it's sort of
alright alright link yeah this is
something that I find pretty disgraceful
actually because we've had that tag kind
of thrown at us a couple of times and
the one thing the first thing is that
every single thing we've ever written
about the old right has been absolutely
scathing you know we pour identity
politics of all forms whether that's
kind of white identitarian ism or any of
the other forms you see on a university
campus for instance and we've been
denouncing that movement in no uncertain
terms of a very long time and I can't
work out whether the way in which that
label was thrown around is just wilfully
malicious or it's just incredibly
ignorant because historically we've
always been Pro immigration Pro
universalism the idea that racial
boundaries gender boundaries all these
things should kind of melt away and I
think that it can only be someone who
either just wants to try and smear us or
someone who has never actually read
anything that we have possibly said but
it is interesting I think it says
something about the times that were in
that that label seems to be being thrown
about so liberally unfortunately I think
it's both isn't it and suppose people
who haven't read a single thing you
mentioned University campuses one of the
things we really wanted to talk to you
about is the unsafe space tour what you
did I think it was last year yes yeah
yeah and tell us a little bit about that
what that involved how that went mm-hmm
so the unsafe space tour was a project
that we did in the US we've been doing a
lot of work on the issue of free speech
on campus in the UK and we but we really
wanted to kind of take it to the heart
where it was happening because as much
as these debates are really raging on UK
campuses things are even more intense
over there even though it's a country
where up so you have this tradition of
the First Amendment and it's seen as
kind of more of a foundational principle
that might be here so we put together
this tour we went to its Harvard
University we were American University
although we got kicked out there's a
story in that
we went to Rutgers University in New
Jersey and I'm probably forgetting some
others but it was the aim of it was
first of all to kind of take head on the
issue of free speech on campus what that
was all about what does the rise of
identity politics mean in relation to
this what does the rise of a new
increasingly liberal form of feminism
play into this all these kind of
different touch tones but I think the
other thing we wanted to do kind of
leading off on your question on the
right actually was to try and reclaim
the free speech argument from people who
were using it to incredibly cynical and
self promoting ends you know this was
the time in which you had a lot of these
kind of right-wing trolls windup
merchants going to university campuses
upsetting students and then making hay
out of it and one of the really
unfortunate things that was going on
sickly in the US was the the debate
about freedom of speech just became a
left-right culture war and if you were
in favor of freedom of speech it's
because you want it to basically shout
obscenities among minorities Mystica and
that the left were entirely just these
kind of snowflakes who had no idea what
free speech was it's not really like
that so we got together this series of
speakers who we felt really excelled at
kind of putting the kind of liberal to
libertarians even progressive case for
freedom of speech so along with our own
Brendan O'Neill who spoke at a couple of
events Steven Pinker from Harvard spoke
guy called Camille Foster spoken on
identity politics panel Mark Lilly a few
others and so the whole aim of it really
was to try and be upfront in sort of
tackling this problem of censorship of
protests against because people dislike
identity politics etc but to do it in
such a way that drew out what we think
is some of the more important arguments
for it which I think classically liberal
and even progressive which that
particular time seemed to be almost
entirely absent from the debate felt why
I mean why is it do you think that the
right wing you know the mum you talk
about freedom of speech
everybody goes well you know that's just
you know that's just right-wing people
when you know and people a lot of people
would say that there's no problem with
freedom of speech particularly in this
country when you compare it with I don't
know Venezuela China or whatever else
why do you think people associate
freedom of speech with the right wing I
think the first thing is to say that it
feels like broadly speaking the kind of
censorship on a kind of state level as
well as the source essentially you see
on a university campus just because the
way things are at the moment it tends to
be people either on a campus
could just be anyone he's kind of you
know to the to the right of center
effectively observes being censored
because of the political cultural motion
university campuses and then I think
broadly speaking I think people think of
censorship ultimately is something which
is reserved for far-right nut cases and
racists you know and that is there's
there's some truth in that but
nevertheless I think the other aspect to
it is there has been this profound kind
of confusion as to first of all the fact
that if you censor anyone in any
circumstance that there is a point at
which that will be used against people
you happen to agree with and I think
we're seeing that play out in relation
to some kind of old feminist finding
themselves on the receiving end of
censorship etc but the other thing I
think is the kind of this sort of
historical illiteracy of it really it
doesn't really take much for a political
culture to change and if you kind of
create the means through which what are
deemed to be extreme views can be
snuffed out either by the state or by
you know by campaigns or by university
administrations or whatever it won't be
long until those same tools are used
against you and I think what's kind of
interesting about kind of even
characters on the kind of us all right
or release all light is they're
increasingly kind of getting people shut
down you know James Gunn this guy who
was directing the guardians of the
galaxy series effectively a bunch of
kind of like journalists dug up his old
tweets and got him sacked because this
dynamic say on social media where things
you might have said jokes you might have
made in the past that were offensive can
be used to effectively get you sacked
that cudgel can be swung by the other
side just as easily so I think it's it
tends to be it does I think it's a
combination of where the political
culture is at the moment but also
unfortunately just an incredible kind of
shortsightedness on behalf of a lot of
left-wing as these days that's why I was
saying that issues like once you invent
this weapon mmm of destroying people's
lives and livelihoods because they made
some joke or whatever you don't get to
control who uses it and and I think a
lot of people on the Left are now
finding it being used against them and I
don't agree with it being used in either
direction mmm
but I think once you once you make it
legitimate to discredit somebody on the
basis of a tweet they post at a three
o'clock in the morning or whatever
that's that's that's then becomes the
norm mmm but that becomes the way that
war the culture was waged no exactly I
think we're really starting to see that
that's going on both sides now you know
if you
compare the Roseann situation in the US
where she obviously tweets this kind of
pretty racist stuff effectively and then
instantly there's this very concerted
effort to get us act you saw the flip
side of that with the James gun thing
now we could argue who are those two
people we find more amiable who if we
might agree with more and I'm sure where
all of us would but nevertheless it's
quite clear that as soon as you create
this dynamic it will be exploited by the
other side and it what I think the most
irritating thing about all of this is
the fact that it's a lot often people
who claim to be very radical who claim
to be about kind of really challenging
the consensus etc who are very keen on
censorship which to me is insane if you
go about branding everyone you just like
an extremist and insisting they be shut
down then if you are someone who's
trying to further radical ideas that's
something which is an incredible threat
to yourself and I think what it actually
shows is that vast sections of the left
today even though they like to pose as
very radical I think the fact that
they're so comfortable with censorship
speaks the fact that deep down whether
they realize it or not they're not
actually saying very much there's
actually that challenging to the status
quo and to those in power more often
than not they seem to be on the side of
people who want to bolster state power
to do things that and to crush people
they disagree so I think it's quite
revealing on that level and do you think
students have become more censorious mmm
it's a tricky one because I the last
thing I want to do is kind of smear all
students and I kind of don't do any work
[Music]
I think I think it's definitely the kind
of extremes of student politics are
becoming more extreme and they're
becoming more vocal and I think the one
thing that has really been the
difference is the fact that where there
was always other people in the room
could be student politics could be
people within a university
administration who would kind of stick
up for themselves who would say look
we've invited this speaker but you can't
just on the basis of a small group of
you who are protesting this shut this
down because there are people who want
to hear this perspective challenged
disrespected etc you know University
administration's
would previously you know consider free
speech to be a kind of guiding value and
would resist attempts to kind of censor
you know even up until about 10 15 years
there would always be these arguments in
these battles but the extent to which
these small groups of campaigners could
succeed was always somewhat more limited
because there were at least enough
people willing to stick up for freedom
of speech I think the big problem is
that a lot of these student protesters
these kind of intense identitarian
people are really thin skinned they've
been given the moral authority in these
situations people even are really
concerned about disagreeing with them
because they know the abuse that could
be held with them etc so there's a
there's an element I think of kind of
cowardice on behalf of a lot of
university administration say and I
think in relation to students more
broadly I think there's a very strong
conformist climate which makes them more
likely to either just keep their mouth
shut or just kind of leave them to it so
I think that whilst these people are
always kind of existing I think the big
change now is unfortunately there's just
so little pushback against them and I
think that has allowed them to kind of
chalk up more wins insofar as censoring
people and but also for their ideas
become more and more strange and more
and more extreme because there's no one
really in the room to kind of temper and
challenges so what you're saying really
is not the students who have become lost
and surahs it's that the silent majority
has been coming creaturely more silent I
think's I mean I do start seeing those
things changing I mean because a lot of
the work that we've been doing sitting
in the UK has been directly with
students we've run kind of tours of
universities working with students to
self debates before we've worked with
them on developing our University
Rankings which we've done in the last
four years which looks at free speech
policies etc and there is a growing
number of them of left right and neither
who are increasingly appalled by this
and they kind of recognize that a lot of
this really holds them in contempt in
particular because if you go around
saying that we can't have this speaker
on campus because it will hurt you it
will it will effectively either hurt you
psychologically or you might be stupid
enough to be won over by people were
really reacting to that and a kind of
visceral way and I also think because of
the fact that the bar for censorship on
campuses be getting lower and lower I
mean up until about 10 years ago it was
really only about kind of far-right
nutcases that this debate was had out
you know as of a few years ago the
stories you're seeing in the newspapers
birmingham university banning sombreros
and i think this is correct a kind of
vision she can't stop reiation because
it's cultural programs let's play this
the suppression thing yeah what are some
other examples of things that have
happened I'm trying to think so there's
there's a lot around fancy-dress which
is quite interesting also cultural
appropriation is it's a strange mix
began to say this what's interesting
about a lot of these kind of calls to
sensitive I mean I don't know who
they've got in mind when they say that
it's almost like in the thing about when
people are obsessed with this cultural
appropriation issue is that they
actually reaffirm stereotypes which kind
of Ray they're suggesting this will be
you know offensive to X why was that
group I think it's the thing that really
makes not so much laugh but worry I
guess it's the fact that you've even had
it seems like so many kind of people in
Student Union's who actually do the
lion's share of this kind of censorship
on campus they always have so little
self-awareness that you have ridiculous
situations like no gangster costumes or
things that we've been saying seeing
recently over the last couple of years
which is free speech societies for
instance being blogs and I think my
favorite example was a couple of years
ago at University of Oxford where a
bunch of students got together in
response to become stories climate on
campus and wanted to start a free speech
magazine called no offense yeah and it
was banned from the freshers fair I
think that's just I think goes to shows
the fact that so much that we see on
campus it's so ridiculous
yeah it's often tempting I think whether
you're a student there or actually just
looking on to think why does it matter
but I think actually it speaks to how
unchecked a lot of this has gone because
we're not even talking about things that
anyone with a modicum of common sense
would think we're a problem anymore it's
really gotten that bad it feels I mean
how much of this is students you know
overreacting and let's be fair we were
all 18 none of us would it ever probably
if ever want to have a conversation with
ourselves at 18 19 and how much of this
is something more sinister mmm no I
think in one sense I think it's
important to say that of course students
are always going to be I like to think
the kind of sharp end of a lot of what's
going on in politics at the moment and
you like to be radical they're
idealistic
they you know you could say kind of take
things to a kind of just a slightly
fervor extreme
I think I think that's definitely part
of it and I think the issue is that of
course there's a generational element to
this I mean it's quite clear that there
is a cohort you could see if and kind of
Millennials onwards down to the kind of
younger generations who have been
socialized into a climate which is very
hostile to freedom of speech hate speech
laws for instance in this country have
been tightened up over the last 15 20
years
intensively whether you agree or
disagree with them I think that sets the
kind of precedent in people's minds that
there is certain opinion certain views
certain statements which are so
abhorrent that they shouldn't be heard I
think that's one thing which is quite
clear and I think there's also the
question of kind of multiculturalism as
a kind of policy of government insofar
as not multiculturalism in relation to
diversity that everyone enjoys and
everyone is most people are relaxed
about but the kind of idea that there
are very distinct cultural and even
racial groups who have certain ideas and
it's kind of rude to discuss them to
challenge them or to kind of assume that
we might through talking with each other
kind of developer kind of common forum
that's been an idea that I think a lot
of young people have been fed and I
think makes people very nervous and more
likely to cry Islamophobia when there's
a discussion about religion etc and I
think the other thing is that there is a
kind of culture of sort of almost self
esteem management that seems to be
driven into young people from a young
age insofar as the idea that words
really hurt they're kind of ramping up a
various kind of anti-bullying policies
et cetera things that Claire Fox had
previous guests on your show has written
a lot about and I think that kind of
feeds the very in some cases kind of
narcissistic character a lot of campus
censorship which is like this offend me
personally it harms me as an individual
and therefore no one should be allowed
to hear it so I think there's different
factors but I think the the court the
common things all of those things is the
fact that these are things that they
were socialized into they're not
entirely of their making I mean if
people are going around assuming that
this generation just kind of emerged out
of the womb we've kind of blue hair and
crazy opinions and
there are actually you know they didn't
spring out nowhere and I think you can
really perceive the Koch from trends
which have fed into a situation in which
a small but if I'm quite vocal minority
of students think it's entirely
acceptable it's a basically crush
opinions they dislike I think the kind
of progression of that is becoming more
clear
well Claire Fox may at that point
actually that you know if there is an
element of snowflake debris around it's
not the fault of them students of the
young people it's the fault of the
parents the education system who've made
them that way and I don't know when you
talk about sensitivity in trigger
warnings I don't know if you saw there
was an article recently about a study
that came out which basically shows that
if we convince people that something
they're about to read is going to hurt
them they then become more prone to
being hurt by that thing so trigger
warnings are actually counterproductive
in them they essentially brainwash
people into thinking that the material
that they might have been triggered by
and will definitely trigger them and
then they become much more fragile and
much less resilient so do you think this
culture is going to have a long-term
repercussions for our society I think it
will insofar as I think it just it
poisons politics I think in some
different ways because I think if you're
going around this kind of intense sense
of sensitivity as well as the identity
politics which I think really attaches
itself very firmly to the question of
censorship
the number one reason cited most times
for why a certain speak on campus should
be banned is that they offend X Y Zed
religious culture or you know social
sexual orientation group etc that's the
main justification for these two things
and I think the consequences of that
even though we should be careful about
being too alarmist and suggesting that
you know everyone's going to be marching
around crushing anyone who you know
doesn't toe the party line in five years
time is that I think that Brees a
certain level of fragility on behalf of
people as you say it basically
encourages people to feel aggrieved
upset by things that would even wouldn't
even bother people you know ten fifteen
years ago but I think the other
byproduct of it is that because of the
identity politics itself and feeds it is
that it's serving I think to really
reify a lot of the kind of racial
divisions that a lot of people struggle
so far to get over I mean if you're
constantly suggesting that certain
particular groups are incredibly fragile
and it's all the
full of a different group over here
that's only going to foster the kind of
tensions that mercifully have been kind
of fading away over the last ten years
so I think that even though we shouldn't
be too alarmist about this I think the
consequences of that for politics for a
free debate and also just for how people
feel around each other in a social
situation at university or wherever I
can see that having quite damaging
effects but surely you do need to draw
the line somewhere because I mean could
you really have like a Richard Spencer
coming and doing a speech on it I think
he's banned from the UK anyway but say
in America going to do a speech here at
Harvard
yeah I mean there has to be free speech
but certainly on there limits to it and
don't we still have to know platform
certain people well I think I think the
thing about free speech is it is for all
it's been on at all because as soon as
you make qualifications on it as soon as
you say some people are so extreme that
they shouldn't be allowed to hurt then
that what is deemed to be extreme will
be something which is up which will
become a political football which can be
expanded which can be applied to people
on the other end of the spectrum or
whatever I think it is it's the slippery
slope in aspect and I think the other
point in that is that it's a really
important progressive argument for
freedom of speech for out the years is
that free speech is the best means
through which you challenge and not
prove bigotry I mean this is a point
that Frederick Douglass the former slave
and abolitionist made in the US and this
speech or this article Roberts called a
plea for free speech in Boston where he
makes this very powerful point that if
free speech in the US was allowed to
exist because it was very tampered by
various kind of mobs who would shut down
abolitionist meetings etc he said that
if free speech was allowed to flourish
in the US then it would break every
chain in the south and banish the
auction block that was always a kind of
foundational point and I think it's kind
of common sense I mean you can't tackle
a bigotry that you you are effectively
pretending doesn't exist by refusing to
engage with it I think the problem that
we're in now is actually something a
little bit more complicated because the
thing about characters like Richard
Spencer is that they're ultimately
incredibly marginal strange odd and very
unrepresentative people but because
there is this culture of censorship and
of wanting to shut these people down and
also want you to constantly kind of
point to them as proof that society is
still as toxic as it might have been in
any other era you make them far more
prominent
than they need be and I think he's an
interesting example because he was
trying to give a speech at a university
in Florida about a year or so ago I
think and the response was so ridiculous
you know they spent about half a million
dollars or something on protecting this
event police all in the streets there
were people being turned away and about
just over a dozen of his supporters
showed up completely surrounded by
protesters who were kind of shouting him
down and there is part of me that things
whilst of course and whenever you come
across views that disgusting you want to
rail against you want to protest and
people should that's how you really and
that's how you really uproot and
challenge bigotry but at the same time I
think there's a byproduct which we're
kind of creating folk Devils who don't
need to be puffed up at the moment and I
do think when you look at the likes of
Richard Spence and when you look at
these kind of alright lunatics it seems
like a more fitting response would just
be allow them to kind of like z-cars to
each other in drafty rooms by themselves
you know there's a kind of question of
proportion here I think but I think yeah
the moment in which you draw the line
you the more you make these problems
worse I someone like Richard Spencer
rather than better let me imagine for a
second if I was a progressive sensoria
student the counter-argument that I
might put you it would be over the last
20 years the kind of things that it's
acceptable to say to somebody mm-hmm
have changed right and that has
coincided with a period of time wouldn't
has been political correctness and
there's been an increasing sensitivity
we've all had a little bit of extra you
know awareness of other people isn't the
fact that we're now less willing to
insult minorities and women and other
people
isn't that a reflection of the fact that
this movement has been a positive thing
for society well I think the thing about
political correctness is that people
often attribute it to things that have
kind of nothing to do with first of all
they kind of conflate it with manners
and no one's against manners you know no
one is a case the fact that people don't
address each other in kind of horrendous
ways but also political correctness as I
can't broadly speaking and how you
define it is it becomes a bit of a
bloated term it's thrown around a lot
but broadly speaking of kind of moved
particularly in academia to suggest that
if you effectively demonize certain
words and tried to snuff them out that
that would have the knock-on effect of
making society and more harmonious you
know in some sort of way I think it
effectively tries to take credit for a
process of integration of anti-racist
activism of society slowly becoming more
at ease with itself and kind
give it to people in the ivory tower but
you know there's the fact of the matter
is the reason people don't shout racial
obscenities down the streets of people
is not because of the fact that some
academic went around shushing them you
know is because views have changed
certain groups have been considered
we've been considered beyond the pale
for a long time but nevertheless have
been successfully shown to be as toxic
as they really are and people are more
integrated people are more relaxed
around one each one another etc so I
think the thing about the political
correctness thing is it is trying to
basically claim credit for a process of
change and anti-racist activism and just
society becoming more and more
integrated which I think it really had
nothing to do with and in its current
form I think is actually driving more
division than it is actually kind of
alleviating it insofar as making things
so hypersensitive so over-the-top
microaggressions etc that actually I
think have the opposite effect which is
to make people feel more nervous around
engaging people who aren't like them
rather than more relaxed about it what
some micro aggression so micro
aggression for those in my life who
really are it's easy to go no no no it's
like you say if I asked you where you're
from
you know first me yeah right that's
implying that you're foreign
okay and therefore it's implying that
you are other yeah therefore it's me
trying to undermine your self-esteem and
make you feel bad about yourself okay so
they're just behaving really like
they've just smoked too much weed they
just get a paranoid there's a huge
element of parent I mean it's the sort
of thing wait to me if you're being
really cynical about it you would say
it's the problem where it feels like the
increasingly society becomes more kind
of egalitarian you have to find more and
more small things to be upset about I
mean some people firstly it's like
they're kind of Saint George in
retirement syndrome we slayed the dragon
now he's gonna go around slaying smaller
and smaller animals there is a bit of
that to it but that effectively it kind
of comes down to this question of you
know some universities in America have
even kind of drawn up lists of things
that you shouldn't say to an ethnic
minority person where you're from being
one of them
some of it is things that you could say
are kind of like clumsy with a kind of
racial tinge to them telling someone
who's black that they're very articulate
which we could also a bit awkward a bit
unpleasant not always said with the
malice that some people would like to
attach them but also things I think
broadly speaking people can kind of
challenge and deal with in a sort of
friendly situation then in the US in
particular has been some universities
which have drawn up lists to them I
think they're quite corrosive first of
all because of the fact that what it's
effectively preaching is a strange kind
of racial etiquette you should treat
people not naturally as that you would
treat any human being but that you would
adjust your behavior in order to treat
them in a particular way and with kid
gloves and I think that's pretty
patronizing and kind of strange but I
think the other thing it does is it's
kind of it microaggressions are actually
pretty useful example of how identity
politics actually reifies racial
differences because on one university
campus I think it was University of
California which campus will get some of
their microaggressions including saying
things like America is a melting pot and
I don't believe in race because that was
deemed to be incredibly insensitive
someone who might be still experiencing
oppression etcetera so I think it is
ridiculous and thankfully it's not quite
as widespread particular in the UK as it
is in other parts of campus life but I
think it's actually quite a useful
example of how racial differences racial
tensions on some level that's kind of
being ginned up again where people who
claim to be in favor of the opposite
[Music]
I feel like so far we've basically so
that I don't have any course to disagree
with anything that you said one thing I
want to toss you back because a lot of
our audience I know from experience of
people who are concerned about the level
of immigration into this country people
who are who might be aligned with
everything that spiked writes about and
talks about it but on that issue I think
there might be quite fundamental
difference so why don't you give us your
your best defense of of mass immigration
and almost I don't know if you have
probe and borders Glenn but you your
view and immigration anyway do I think
that the point that Speights always made
historically in relation to immigration
it is a kind of question of freedom and
it's the ability of people's gonna
flourish wherever they are around the
world and to be able to be on the move
and it's also kind of question of so
many of the arguments against
immigration historically in particular
the current period have often had to do
with the kind of low horizons of that
particular society one of which is the
idea that we there's some people who
just can't be integrated you know it's a
kind of classic you know almost like
power like kind of hot it's kind of
existed there's also the kind of broader
idea that there's only so much of nation
can produce you know that someplace is
kind of full an argument used to be made
by outright racialist and is
increasingly made by can green people in
relation to the question of immigration
but I think the thing that's actually
complicated the argument of immigration
more broadly is the question of
citizenship because a lot of the mass
immigration we've experienced has not
only never been done with the say-so of
the electorate
you know European free movement this was
never something that there was a
referendum on that people knew that they
were signing up to this was always a
kind of a leap process through which
that was introduced and similarly I
think has come hand-in-hand with a
process by which what it means to be a
citizen in a sort of democratic country
has been increasingly undermined and the
idea that a nation should have a
particular political culture and a
center which people from various
different origins and roots can kind of
meet in the middle and understand
themselves as part of one entity has
increasingly been painted as something
suspect you know the idea that there
should just be diversity for its own
sake rather than some sort of common
culture so I think actually a lot of the
anxieties around immigration I think
they've been entirely decoupled in the
large part from the kind of racist
arguments in the past that was quite
in many respects you know concern about
immigration is maintained largely
speaking in the last few years even as
racial animus that's it that's exactly
it wasn't it you're actually people's
hostility toward immigrants has been
dropping rapidly and at the same time as
concerns about immigration levels have
been rising hmm exactly quickly and I
that's to me that's a fascinating
argument which brings us straight on to
brexit which is something that we
because this will go out a few weeks
from now yeah we have no idea who is
who's gonna be the prime minister of
this country who's gonna be the foreign
secretary is there gonna be a break this
and not gonna be a break sir but one of
the things and we've talked about it so
much on the show is then how as an
immigrant myself to this country how
frustrating I find that the argument
about brexit mm-hmm has been confused as
an argument about xenophobia racism when
I think it really is very little to do
with that yeah but one of the so we
don't want to get too much into breaks
into the nuance of it but we talked
before we started about the idea that
brexit is a good indicator of the fact
that mainstream opinions or the majority
opinions and society are becoming
unpalatable in polite society tell us
tell us what you think about that no I
think that's one of the things that was
most revealing kind of shocking about
the brexit vote
I think the comedian Jeff nor course
made this made this point released this
joke before is that you're in a
situation where the majority position is
the one that's demonized that's really
weird because again the old idea of safe
free speech for example was kind of
practiced on the idea the fact that the
mainstream can look after itself what
most people think what is broadly
speaking a consensus is not something
that needs the protection of free speech
it's all about them kind of batty ideas
on the edges which need that protection
because they're always going to be the
ones which are demonized but I think
what we've seen recently is again the
majority of the electorate in a
particular referendum vote for something
in numbers that you know we haven't seen
for any other vote in British political
history and yet it's treated as
something aberrant strange vicious
racist and something which must be kind
of crushed at all cost and I think
what's in the one hand it shows the fact
that we're in this bizarre position that
the majority position is demonized but
really that is born of the fact that the
gap between the electorate and the
people they elect has become so wide
that not only do they not agree on
something but also they the elite has a
tendency to assume the worst about those
people in every single situation and
just the simple fact that 52% in the
referendum voted leave was about 75% of
MPs voted remain I think tells you
everything about that and what's been
even more shocking about the kind of
post brexit vote situation is the fact
that you would think that given there
was this huge blow to the political
classes authority all of the main
parties advocating remain the country
voting leave but that would force some
kind of reassessment for them to think
maybe we're not in touch with the people
who vote for us maybe there's something
that we're missing about people wanting
more control over their own lives in
their own societies the sneering
actually got worse and it got more
explicit and it got more extreme and
it's been going on like that for over
two years now so I think what that
bizarre situation we find ourselves in
where the majority position is demonized
is largely a product of the fact that
the elites have been becoming ever more
distant if it was like from the public
and increasing not caring about that
effect and I think that's really aside
from the question of how an if and when
brexit it's actually implemented is the
broader issue for our democracy that we
need to try and bring back together
because I think that's really sort of
next story isn't it though I mean one of
the things that was interesting with the
breaks that campaign was where you had
people like Katie Hopkins I mean looking
back because you know you're a staunch
break City do you think that that was
actually a mistake by the leave campaign
because then it was very very easy for
people who in the remain campaign to go
well it's obviously racist hmm you know
look at the fact that you know Katie
who's going on TV and saying frankly
intolerant things hmm no I mean it was
that's definitely the case of this
there's going to be people on the side
of something good who do it for bad
reasons I mean there's less always gonna
be examples of that and I think it's
important not to smear the majority of a
particular position on the basis of what
some you know people would ill intent
actually want to want to do with that
kind of thing I think in relation to the
brexit question the thing that made that
more potent was the fact that the left
had completely abandoned the cause of
your skepticism
I mean spite broadly speaking coming out
of a left-wing you're a skeptic
tradition and even at the time of the
referendum the Labour Party was being
led by so
on Jeremy Corbyn who spent his entire
political life being a staunch euro
skeptic a hard brexit ear in the current
kind of Lang and the fact that even
various kind of commentators people who
write for you know newspapers who had
previously been of that kind of
left-wing Euroskeptic you abandoned it
because they effectively lost their
bottle and I think they gave in to this
very specious argument that's just
because you so happen to believe to
agree with someone like Katie Hopkins on
this one particular issue does not mean
you're tainted by that but I think
unfortunately just by dint of their own
kind of cowardice they effectively
abandoned the field and that made it so
much easier for people to say well look
who's on that side you know that's what
that side is all about but I think that
again with the referendum campaign one
of the best things to come out of it is
that people in voting leave and even
people who voted remain given you see
the number of people who still think is
something that should be implemented in
a you know what they might be concerned
about it know that that must be done is
that I don't think they bought into that
kind of that kind of guilt by
association and I think the result kind
of proves how the attempt to do that
really don't wash with most people I
think they see write for it you know
what troubles me with this whole brexit
conversations in fact you're going on my
[Laughter]
yeah you know what troubles me with this
whole break something is we actually had
a meeting with some I'm not gonna name
names well we had a meeting with someone
who I really respect in both Francis and
I voted remain and she voted leave and
we were talking about you know we're
doing the show whatever and she was like
well you guys are remain as I'm a brexit
it and I didn't say anything at the time
but I actually thought that is an
incredibly unhelpful way that we talking
about each other because I'm not a
remainer
mmm I voted to remain but that doesn't
make me an identity of a person who's
remain I'm not out there campaigning
yeah to reverse the referendum or
whatever whatever people put to that
label I just want to remain you know
maybe I had no clue which way to what
maybe I flipped a coin on the day
how do you know that I'm a remain what
does it mean that you're a brexit in you
know we've got these rigid identities
now what if I changed my mind what if
I'd suddenly go yeah normal breaks as a
great idea
we'll send Frances back to Venezuela
right hmm so that that's what troubles
me is this rigidity of identities ah
we've become like different tribes mm
and there is not the kind of like you
know you voted to leave we want to turn
my we can still have a conversation we
don't need to think about each other's
different species of animals you know
and I think it's kind of interesting
because I think the big divide now
broadly speaking is between Democrats
and anti Democrats I think whether
you're a remainder or lever ceased to
mean much on the 24th of June 2016 I
mean it's I think the the reason that
people speak so much about the idea that
this is is these two tribes still that
the country is more divided than it's
ever been which I think you just can't
substantiate is driven by the fact that
they're trying to effectively use people
who voted remain as a kind of staged
army against implementing the results
whereas if you look at polling if you
look at the electoral failures of saying
the Liberal Democrats you kind of paint
themselves a week and Hoover up this 48%
and got one of the worst results you
know in recent years I think just speaks
to the fact that most people cease to be
remainders or leaves on that question
most people know that when a referendum
and this magnitude is taken that of
course the thing has to be implemented
and I think a lot of this talk about
division I just don't really see it most
people who voted leave know a lot of
people who voted remain and vice versa
we're not beating each other up in the
streets and it's just I think often that
kind of all that question about division
and the idea that yes there are these
kind of two tribes I think it's only
really in elite circles that that's kind
of talked about mainly because they
don't have much experience outside of
those quite rarefied circles oh come on
are you not being naive and saying the
people on divide I mean I know a lot of
people who we don't speak to their
parents or don't speak to their sister
or their brother some people got
divorced over lists I hear anecdotes
about this but I just don't see it
personally
now that's anecdote versus anecdote I
suppose but then the only thing that the
thing I would suck up next to that is
again if you look at the kind of the
polling for all of this and as far as
the seven out of ten people think that
the vote should be implemented that's
much higher than the 52% and I can't
just be remainders who suddenly think
leave is a great idea
either and I just feel like there's
there's a tendency particularly on the
kind of continuity remain campaign side
to present the what is effectively a
very slim part of the population has
actually far bigger than actually is and
I think this calls for this talk about
division just plays into that too neatly
I'm not saying that people didn't have
these issues over breaks I'm sure it did
happen in certain circles but on the
extent that's being talked about I don't
really buy it I guess
why is bracelet such a good idea I mean
nobody goes oh you know I hear so much
about it yeah I voted remain because on
all honesty I'm quite conservative and
I'm quite an anxious person I'm like
well we're doing pretty well within the
EU why change you're quite conservative
crush appalled Tories come yeah Tory
scum hashtag no um I just I just thought
the why change a winning formula this
country was doing one under the EU I
thought anyway I think I think that's
there's various different arguments kind
of involved in this I guess I'll just
pick out one and that is the democratic
argument insofar as in myriad ways the
European Union limits democracy you know
from everything we've talked about from
effectively from many positions of left
or right if you just want simply to
control your borders which isn't
necessarily even a right-wing position
but one that a lot of people on the
right are concerned about you can't do
that as a member of the European Union
and that's a policy which we have
adopted irreversibly by dint of being EU
members that we cannot have any control
over whilst we're still members
similarly if you say even something like
some of the policies pretty like Social
Democratic policies and someone like
Jeremy Corbyn wants to implement stay a
debt cetera you couldn't implement that
whilst being a member of the European
Union and that the entirety of the kind
of structure is designed to limit the
scope of politics within member states
and also becomes very helpful for our
elected politicians to effectively
outsourced responsibility for various
things that they used to have to do in
relation to a country decisions they
have to take ideas out to think about
and to this distant bureaucracy who
would effectively do it for them and I
think the main thing is it's a question
of democracy control self-determination
that comes with risks because who knows
what might be around the corner but at
the same time considering how the
European products are impending out with
ten years I don't think we can say the
brexit is the only risky option either
but I think it all comes down to a point
that again kind of as we were talking
about kind of the strange death of left
us skepticism but you know jeremy
corbyn's great here it's only been said
was that you'd rather have a bad
Parliament and a good king and I think
that's a crucial argument in relation to
breaks it and why despite who knows what
will happen next that's the main reason
why I think we were right to vote to
leave and that's the ultimate promise of
it's just more control of ordinary
people over the people who govern them
but I mean doesn't it feel at the moment
and maybe again I'm buying too
mainstream media it just feels that
there's chaos I mean like there's the
issue with the border in Northern
Ireland nobody really knows what's going
on with that the fact that I was reading
an article about that you know there's a
tent with Dover with the port there's
gonna be massive issues people talking
about the army coming in with surprise
we're gonna run out of insulin do you
know I mean is it worth it I mean is
well first of all I think we have to
take some of these problem
certifications with a bit of Pinscher so
I mean some of the things are being
talked about at the moment we're things
that we actually heard during the remain
campaign itself about what would happen
immediately after a brexit vote you know
the idea that would be instant recession
that there would be problems in relation
to bring things into the country these
are things that we have heard before and
I mean the fact that people are
effectively saying that people will die
if this happens whenever someone makes
that kind of a claim in politics and
they're not actually talking about
they're not talking about a war then
you've got a question there's kinds of
arguments it's just classic
fear-mongering but I think in relation
to how chaotic things are I think a lot
of that speaks to the fact that first of
all brace it was never going to be an
easy process because of the fact that
the European Union does not want this to
be a success for us their main concern
is not even their own economic
self-interest it's holding the project
together and if brexit or leaving the
European Union begins to look like
something which is you know bit of a
rocky road but something which isn't
necessarily going to be too difficult
and of course there's going to be many
countries many place on the continent a
far more Euroskeptic than Britain even
is and to start considering it as a
viable option but I actually think the
fact that it was always going to be
difficult and it's been exacerbated by
the fact that it's being negotiated by
the political class we rejected in
voting for brexit most people not only
in this government but in
Parliament don't actually agree with it
and at the very worst even if at the
very best rather even if they know that
it has to be implemented or terrified of
actually implementing it so I think the
extent to which there is a lot of chaos
and uncertainty I think it speaks to the
fact that there has been this very
fearful uncertain and often quite
botched approach to actually
implementing it so we should take a lot
with this with a pinch of salt ball so
just recognize that this is the battle
that we have on our hands Biden of
trying to actually force through
something and get our politicians to
implement something that none of them
actually wanted in the first place see
if you want brexit to happen you need a
real brexit ear gets involved in brits
it gets fired if there was like a cheap
horror movie suddenly the character
turns up they're dead the next one turns
up they're dead it just keeps going on
what's going on so you talk about
particular people in cabinet David Davis
yeah loads of them just seem to turn up
for a couple of weeks and then burst
again I mean right now I mean this might
change as you're saying matter of days
but all of the main offices of state are
held by people devoted remain someone's
campaign quite peacefully for me and I
think it just gets to the point of first
of all the fact that there's been this
assumption the Tory party is kind of the
party of brexit but it never has been a
majority of Tory MPs voted for remain
and even though the party membership is
broadly speaking quite Euroskeptic is
it's certainly not that way on the high
levels and I think it just pieces us out
on the one hand I think the kind of
inability of a lot of people who even
though they presented themselves as the
kind of heroes and the leaders of brexit
people like Boris Johnson failed really
to kind of stand up for it when it
really mattered but too likely to kind
of capitulate in so many situations
which made their positions increasingly
untenable I think but it also I think to
speak to the fact that again the core
contradiction you make a vote against a
political class it's now left for a
political class to implement and I think
the fact that people are dropping like
flies I think speaks to the fact that
they're increasingly proved themselves
either unwilling or unable actually to
kind of implement this as much as people
want there to be and can we make your
success of hard breaks it because
everything I read about it apparently
it's gonna be the end of the world I
mean this is what's so strange about it
because the idea that it's gonna be kind
of
economic Armageddon for all times I mean
the proportion of trade that we live the
European Union has been decreasing over
the past you know 15 20 years as trade
with the rest of the world is increasing
obviously the process of leaving quite
abruptly would have effects no one's
saying that there wouldn't be but at the
same time the one thing the main first
of all I think the kind of Armageddon
claims just don't fully stack up and I
think that can be slightly ludicrous but
also I think actually brexit voters in
particular had no illusions when they
voted I mean there's various bits of
research which suggest that most breaks
it is when they voted for that
particularly in the short term it would
make the economy about as good or maybe
a little bit worse because you know
we're separating ourselves out of this
entire legal and trading order that
we've been intertwine with for decades
but nevertheless I think what the vote
showed was the fact that short-term
economic instability a little trouble at
the ports certain things being things
that we have to kind of contingency plan
for etc is a pretty small price to play
for self-determination and I think it's
pretty upsetting that it feels like that
pretty basic Democratic principle is
something that so many people nearly
feel uncomfortable with and think is so
strange and reckless
[Music]
all right well let's move on a little
bit I wanted to ask you you've debated
Ashe is the Circa kind of soccer or
soccer yeah who recently made headlines
because she went on the Piers Morgan
Susanna Reid show and talked about how
she is literally a communist what do you
make of the rise of this kind of new
socialism in the world where you know
for me coming from Russia I mean I
personally see no difference between
someone saying I'm literally a communism
and saying I'm literally a Nazi to me
there is no difference between those two
ideologies are responsible for a similar
number of deaths in the world communism
probably claimed more lives annually
certainly in my country you know what do
you make of the fact that it's perfectly
normal now for people to go on TV and go
yeah I'm a communist it's luxury
communism luxury call me this lecture
yeah that's it that's what they call it
yeah this is a new rebirth I think it
actually speaks to the I think the fact
that people are selling t-shirts with
I'm literally a communist on them people
are going on was a good morning Britain
and declaring themselves communist
effectively underscores the death of
communism just because of the fact it's
become an incredibly safe and
meaningless category for you know
self-styled radicals in the West I mean
first of all there's a lot of people and
this kind of this fully automated luxury
communism crew they openly campaigning
for Jeremy Corbyn and it was always a
kind of principles they're kind of you
know the far left that the it was almost
worse to support the Labour Party
because they were holding back you know
the kind of Glorious Revolution that
this becomes so a lot of these people
calling themselves communists are
spending their entire days advocating
for a pretty milquetoast Social
Democrats so I think there's a there's
an element of posturing and projection
and a lot of this to be honest but at
the same time I think there is a there's
a tendency especially the kind of
right-wing reaction to a lot of those
statements to give them a little more
credit than that you have to paint them
as more radical more dangerous you know
more serious than they actually are when
broadly speaking I think the way in
which Marxism and communism have kind of
become just poses that people strike
it's something that gets written up in
team vogue has happened with the a
soccer thing I think speaks to the fact
that you
a system of gulags I don't I don't think
so no and I don't think any of the
people saying this stuff would be
capable of such a thing conversion I
think it's just unfortunately I think
the a lot of left-wing labels whether
it's communism Marxism or whatever have
been stripped of a lot of their content
they've just been fashion accessories
that I think a lot of people done and I
think in some respects the kind of the
reaction to it gives them more credit
than these people actually deserve what
they're pushing is far more boring than
they'd like it's interesting because
you'll note that Alexandra has no
quarters he's just elected in America
yeah I'd listen to him if you're Venters
I'm not sure she knows a lot much about
what she's talking about many issues but
one of the questions that was asked to
her she gave a very cogent answer which
I thought was quite relevant she was
asked why young people are increasingly
going for things like social you know
becoming Social Democrats a democratic
socialist socialism social and she said
that if you look at young people say
people who who in their 20s now for
example they've never experienced the
benefits of capitalism in the same way
that our generation people in their 30s
and people older than that have they
came of age after the 2008 crash so all
they know really is expensive housing
economic instability lack of jobs lack
of future so what they're seeing is a
world that doesn't work for them they're
seeing a world in which their future is
likely to be worse than their parents
and and that's why they're looking at
these policies and these parties that
represent in their minds at least
theoretically an opportunity for a
fairer society did you buy into that
argument you think young people are
persuaded by that for that reason I
think it's deafening argue with that I
think the phrases taken something like
the housing crisis which is a huge issue
in the UK and no I never seems to be
able to grapple with if this is a big
problem for the right I think because
you can't expect people without any
capital to be pro-capitalist I mean it
just doesn't make any sense but
nevertheless I think to be honest what
to be slightly more cynical about the
kind of rise of this sort of new form of
socialism this new left-wing
progressivism
not only because I think the extent of
it is often a bit exaggerated but also
it feels like what it means to be a
socialist
which historically is quite an important
and
many point positive doctrine has been
watered down you know you take someone
like Cassio Cortes what she's talking
about it's basically NHS free education
I mean these are not particularly
radical ideas it speaks to how narrow
the political culture in the u.s. often
is that these things are seen as such
but that's kind of quite loose you just
say things like capitalism has had its
day and stuff like that I know but it's
empty sloganeering and I mean for
instance a lot of the people who were
very excitable around the Corbin
movement feel that they're effectively
anti-capitalist but what they would be
voting for is not necessarily gonna kind
of revolutionary program you know I mean
it's the sort of thing where I think
there's a bit of a failure of political
labels in relation to this stuff and I
also think that there's been a bit of a
danger that left-wing politics and
socialism or being a core bit Easter has
kind of become its own breed of identity
politics it often feels quite shallow it
often feels like the center of it is not
entirely clear and it often just becomes
about I'm a good person and you're not
there's there's an element to that which
I think is really key it often feels
about posture rather than substance and
I think one perfect example about that
it's the fact that everyone saying that
they're really Procol been really pros
policies and yeah a lot of them are
pro-eu something which would render
those policies completely inert so I
think it just speaks to the fact that
largely speaking what it means to be a
socialist has kind of been defined down
to some extent and at the same time I
think that it's unfortunately been
absorbed there's a kind of at least for
young people is a con another form of
identity politics so I think we should
kind of temper a lot of the slightly
over excitable or terrified response
that a lot of these new movements have I
think that's slightly different from
what people think they are because one
thing or I've seen I've just been
baffled by is just a backlash against
centrists hmm and then like you know
they do mean sensory serves almost like
another extension of the alright what
the kind of centrist dad's phenomenon
yeah the way around like we have like we
have people calling us Kooks we are not
right-wing as we are centrist
yeah yeah yeah you know so it kind of
comes from both ways like if you're not
on an extreme you're evil
yeah yeah no there isn't there is a lot
of that going on I think the one thing I
would say about that is that obviously
it's ridiculous and there's been this
kind of attempt to by both sides to kind
of just suggest that you know if you
happen to be in the center of politics
that makes you complicit in X Y Zed you
know there's all this cut there's all
these kind of things if you're on the
source
labour party reflectively Ettore all
this kind of stuff is just a bit
infantile and a bit embarrassing but I
think the one thing it's important to
recognize is the fact just because we
live in this age where you do have kind
of crazy people it feels like in the
extreme shouting at each other and into
the darkness all the time about things
that don't really much seem important it
doesn't necessarily mean that the center
is always the most you know the position
that everyone should hold I think it's
fair to say that you could have a
radical left-wing politics say that
wasn't batshit crazy in the same way
that it is possibly that you can have
progressive politics which is aimed at
really fundamentally changing society
that doesn't mean either gulags or
ridiculous identity politics you know it
just feels like the one thing I wouldn't
want people to take away from the very
strange climate for debate and
discussion that were in at the moment is
the idea that's splitting the difference
is always the right way because if
anything the brexit revolt for instance
is really a rejection of that kind of
politics on some level not just centrism
but I think something which is always
particularly in nature of politicians
and political parties that has come with
centrism which is this new technically
see the belief that is better to kind of
outsource power to unaccountable bodies
etc European Union being an example of
it so I think on the one hand whilst it
feels like so few people are being
reasonable and there's this kind of
reasonable people like yourselves in the
center that's not to say the fact that
being more radical in certain ways is
necessarily a dirty word and I think in
fact in many respects brexit is an
example of something which is radical
which could actually change society for
the better along you know against some
of the kind of slightly more centrist or
technocratic trends we've been seeing
the last kind of 20-30 years all right
well thanks for speaking with us the
final question we always like to ask is
is that one thing that no one's talking
about that we ought to be talking about
I think for that I would say what next
and I mean that in relation to Britain
in relation to Europe in America just
with over the last couple of years we've
seen all these kind of revolts against
the establishment they're taking
different forms in different places
sometimes they've empowered people that
we don't like sometimes they've been
something like brexit which was just a
kind of leaderless you know bottom-up
type of revolt but I think the question
for anyone who's interested not just in
something like brexit but the bigger
question about how do you make societies
more democratic open how do we make sure
that people are more can I'm involved in
how these societies are shaped and that
the terms of the debate answer either by
a vocal minority
or by the elites I think the question is
what comes after this how do we carve
out a new politics for a new age and it
feels like all the old politics are
knackered and I think that that at the
moment is the most interesting question
anyone interested in democratic also
progressive politics should be trying to
answer as broad as that yes great before
you go or anything you'd like to plug or
promote on Twitter handle with the
handle or I'm at Tom underscore Slater
underscore but also people should of
course go and check out spikes online
where spiked - online calm and I - it
handles at spite online so not just for
bracket free speech but the whole gamut
of issues you'll find plenty to read
there and I'm at constant kissing on
Twitter I'm a failing human and if you
enjoyed this episode as always subscribe
to our YouTube channel and most most
importantly if you've already subscribed
click that Bell right next to subscribe
button to make sure you get notified
every time we release a video thank you
very much for tuning in as always and
we'll see in a week's time
[Music]